el primer ministro en funciones hasan
diab ha dicho que no colaborará más con
la justicia después de que esta mañana
el juez fadis aguán que lleva las
investigaciones por la explosión del
puerto de beirut le haya acusado tener
licencia a el de atrás ministros de su
gabinete porque conocían la existencia
de las dos mil 750 toneladas de nitrato
de amonio almacenadas en el puerto de
beirut y que a pesar de haber recibido
varias advertencias de la peligrosidad
que suponía tener este tipo de
fertilizante altamente explosivo
almacenado en una zona en el centro de
la ciudad no tomaron ninguna medida de
seguridad día para dicho que él tiene
las manos limpias y la conciencia
tranquila y que ya habló en su momento
cuando fue interrogado después de la
explosión del 4 de agosto que mató a 200
personas hirió a otras seis mil y otras
300.000 personas se quedaron sin hogar
díaz ha acusado al propio juez de haber
violado la constitución
tiene inmunidad política y que debería
haber primero pasado por el parlamento
la acusación antes de haberla hecho no
está claro ni no se sabe los pasos que
tomará el premier libanés pero lo que sí
está claro que no querer colaborar con
la justicia se volverá de nuevo la ira
de los libaneses